okay so spider-man know a home has been
breaking the bank and as of now the film
is the highest grossing movie this side
of the pandemic the film brought
together 20 years worth of franchises in
order to tell a story that bridged the
multiverse and brought across several
peter parkers and also the characters
villains it's one of the best
experiences i've had in a cinema well
ever and though andrew garfield has
finally started talking about how he's
the werewolf we hadn't heard much from
toby and tom that is until now sound a
bit sinister there but last night sony
dropped a big talk between the trio on
their spiderman youtube channel
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the main talking points
whilst also discussing what it means for
the actors and if they could be
returning
[Laughter]
now the first main talking point was
toby discussing how he got involved in
the project and the conversations that
he had around coming back toby said that
after amy pascal and kevin feige pitched
the idea to him he realized it was very
much a celebration of what had come
before but that for him it also went
beyond that but it was really about
getting together with these people and
revisiting
you know what
what was part of my history and getting
a chance to like come together and
um there there are personal things too
which are
um
kind of resolutions or
um a way to revisit and and
um i'm not quite sure how to put it it's
just just to get to get back into that
and
i don't want to say like close the
chapter but revisit and have certain
resolutions
um and and just join in this like loving
creative spirit now toby much like
andrew had his version of the web head
shelved rather than being completed if
you cast your mind back to the aftermath
of spider-man 3 there was very much talk
of a fourth movie being developed and we
even had storyboards for at least last
year which showed a final battle between
the wall crawler and the vulture
unfortunately due to creative
differences sam raimi stepped back from
the project and as we know the character
was then rebooted with andrew garfield
one of the more interesting things that
toby says though is that it's not a
closing of the chapter and we have heard
rumblings behind the scenes that sony
are planning on bringing both garfield
and maguire back this reportedly would
be a project in which they'd appear in
it from the start and it would explore
their stories more in depth the creative
team behind the film actually revealed
that they had several post-credits scene
ideas showing the pair on their own
worlds but that these were taken out by
the studio normally this is done when
there are plans for things going ahead
but they don't want to lock themselves
into anything and i definitely think at
the very least that one of the actors
will return in an upcoming film now
andrew actually talked about coming back
for this movie and he said that it
pretty much all hinged on toby's
shoulders
so for you what was what was it like
going back well i was just waiting to
see if toby was gonna do it and if toby
was gonna do it
and i i was like well i have no choice
you know he
i follow toby to to the ends to the ends
of the earth i'm a lemming for toby um
no i but that was a sincerely a big part
of it you know when when i was
approached about it and
and again it's in a similar way to what
toby was saying it was like oh the
intention feels very pure here it
actually feels
like a great creative idea and a great
creative story it wasn't like they were
just asking us to come and say hi and
then leave again but actually
have us have our presence being in
service to tom
you know being in service to to tom's
journey and and where where he is as
peter parker and how i love the destiny
feeling
of um the multiverse expanding in this
film and actually that without toby's
peter and andrews peter
being present for tom's peter at this
very moment he may not become the peter
parker that he's supposed to become
i love that there's and and and the and
that maybe he'll he would have lost his
girlfriend and that maybe he would have
gone down a darker path if if toby
hadn't have given
hadn't have given um him that that kind
of mentorship moment that better angel
kind of moment
so it was those things i get chills
thinking about it even now now i
definitely agree with andrew's take on
the mentorship thing in the build-up to
the film you might remember that we
talked about how the movie would be
pulling from storylines like one more
day and also happy birthday in the
latter peter ends up interrupting one of
doctor strange's spells and this breaks
open the multiverse he travels into it
and finds a version of himself from the
past and future the latter of which
provides a warning not to go down a
certain path this is definitely an
element that's brought up in the film as
toby stops tom from killing the person
that murdered the parental figure in his
life and andrew saves the woman that he
loves which stops him from having a gwen
stacey moment it's great to see and
another element that andrew mentioned
was how it was more than them just
coming on screen saying hello and then
going off one of my big worries in the
build after the film was that the pair
would just show up for the final battle
but they do get a lot of big character
moments in the movie which i think is
what makes it so special now having
actors of this statue who'd played
spider-man in the past coming into your
film was obviously also big for tom
holland and he went over what it was
like watching them join the project it
was daunting it was very daunting
because we were a long way into shooting
before you guys showed up you know we
were maybe three months into principal
photography
and you know the the date of
the other spidermans are coming was
etched on my calendar and i was getting
closer and closer and closer and you
know the closer and closer i got
the more and more nervous i was and then
as soon as i met you guys in atlanta
i realized i had nothing to be nervous
about
but on our first
at our first rehearsal i had asked jacob
and sender to come with me
to just kind of be there as like
my support system like i'm gonna go meet
these guys i'm really nervous about it
we have to read the scene and i don't
know how this is gonna go because we're
all playing the same character and we
all have to bring our own kind of heart
and soul into this and you know it means
a lot to them and it means a lot to me
does it mean the same
so jacob and they were there on that
first day but i think it was really
strange and almost a little unfair how
they had us put the suits on and then
just jump around
in front of a camera together like that
was one of the most bizarre experiences
of my life and again jacob and zade were
there for that to support me
but it was an amazing experience and
from day one it was a roller coaster
that i didn't want to get off now in the
build up to this movie there were a lot
of leaks and reports talking about how
all three were coming back andrew
garfield constantly kept denying he was
in the movie and almost got to the point
that it was a meme
i heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
i promise you i am not the werewolf are
we going to see you toby and tom in the
new movie
i want to get really clear i want this
is this the unequivocal yes no answer i
did not get a call the interviewer asked
how he managed to keep it all a secret
especially as he was out there doing
press for most of the air and here's
what he had to say it was quite i kind
of enjoyed it it was quite fun and it
kind of it felt like a game of that game
werewolf or mafia where you you know
you're the werewolf and you have to
convince everyone that you're not so i
kind of like turned it into a little bit
of a game for myself
i don't know and it did result in this
kind of like even though there are all
these leaks and all this stuff happening
i think like
there was enough doubt in everyone's
mind going oh god what if it isn't what
if it isn't what if they don't show up
and then so when we did it kind of gave
them that little extra little bit of
icing on top of an already
incredibly deep i watched the movie with
toby for the first time and i was in
pieces like this is a deep movie this
isn't just
fan service which you know it partially
is but like this is a movie that is
about a coming of age like an acceptance
of loss acceptance of death
taking responsibility for your gifts and
the
like i was torn open by the journey that
tom went on and that he was having to it
was just like
having to split with with with his
girlfriend his best friend and sacrifice
that in order it's just it's the it's
classic peter parker but it felt totally
fresh and totally reimagined like
his origin like tom's origin story was
happening in his third movie rather than
his first like there's something so
profound so the film i feel stands alone
without me and me and toby showing up i
hope we enhance it but like i think john
and tom have made just something
actually that is exceptionally
moving especially for young people you
know i think it's i think it's a
beautiful film now i completely agree
with andrew and even though i was fairly
confident that both he and toby were
going to be in it i did have doubt in
the back of my mind about it i even
texted a friend who went to the premiere
asking if they were in it and they just
replied saying what do you think they
didn't reply for a while after that and
i was sat for about six hours thinking
crap i've told everyone they're in it
and they're not gonna have to shut the
whole channel down and come back as
henry spoilers now there was a massive
reaction seeing the pair back on screen
and i think that the film definitely
enhances the main emotional story like
andrew says it does somewhat feel like
an mcu peter parker origin tale and that
final swing in his homemade costume is
given more weight because we now know
that the character is out there on his
own this is rather than him having the
guiding forces that so many of the mcu
movies have been criticized for giving
him and it definitely feels like this
trilogy is a coming-of-age story toby 2
discussed the ending and what he thought
that it meant for not only tom but also
the characters that guided him and and i
too just wanted to say with with the
coda
of the movie i was really
touched emotionally but also i just
thought it had such a sweet elegance to
it like that
was so amazing and i i agree in terms of
the origin story and the kind of coming
of age or or you know
tom your character stepping into this
different kind of maturity and
responsibility
and all done with this like really sweet
sad elegant touch it was it was just
beautiful have you enjoyed the video so
far then don't be a spider menace hit
that thumbs up button your chump or i'm
gonna put some dirt in your eyes if
subscribers were crackers then my
daughter would be fat so why not click
that button too and stick around at the
channel if this is your first time here
and you don't mind crap jokes then
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man now let's get
into the rest of the video now seeing
the three spider-man on screen in the
same frame was a major moment and
garfield talked about how he didn't
really get it at first when they were
hyping it up looking at it from his
perspective he said he didn't fully
grasp how special it was until director
john watts showed them the frame of the
three on the scaffolding together we
just kind of stood here and and both me
and toby were like yeah this feels a
little weird we feel a little odd and
then in that moment john watts comes up
the um
the scaffolding goes
that's the movie that's it we got it
it's the
part of the film this is this is the
moment and we're all like oh
we're insane then
we weren't seeing what he was seeing
which he then just showed us and it was
just the three of us in our suits in the
same frame and just how profoundly
moving that is unto itself
for spider-man fans the world over and i
think it was at that point where i was
like oh no this is gonna people are
gonna like this movie a lot
now toby talked about his time on the
film and what it meant to be playing the
character
there's so much affinity for this
character it means so much to so many
people
that you know once the sort of goofiness
of of being in
uh lycra or spandex you know once that
goes away you're like oh wow this is
this is cool this is a responsibility
but a but a blessing like something that
i get to do that i'm grateful for
and
so that was fun but but honestly like
being with these guys it really was just
a much much richer experience than
i anticipated or
that i could really even express in
words i i just to get to be there with
these guys in their suits and
whether it was like dancing around or
playing around in scenes and improving
or kind of sense of service to each
other
um and the character being in service to
humanity it really
gives a certain perspective and then
and then the the kind of trust and
openness that
i had with these guys and
uh john and amy and everyone it it just
brought this
really
open
i don't know i just felt super
safe and like we we're all on the same
team and all in support of each other
and it just brought out this
this
yeah i don't know how to put it other
than just like this really loving
uh fun creative experience that
um
that i was just like sitting in
gratitude every day now lastly the
interview closed out with tom talking
about what the future for his peter
parker could be and he said that he
genuinely didn't know thomas had to lie
a lot in the press tour for spider-man
knowing home but he stated that he was
genuinely telling the truth this time
and that he would even be happy if this
was goodbye for his version he said that
he did want to continue playing
spider-man but if his arc was to end
with him jumping off a building and
swinging off into the sunset or rather
the night sky then he'd be happy with
that i don't think that he will be done
though and we of course had the teaser
venom at the end of the film there's so
many different directions that they can
take things in his college years and
it's going to be really interesting to
see what happens now that mj and ned are
moving to boston i can't wait and i'm
sure you can't either but until then i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
interview and what you'd like to see
from these guys next now as a thank you
you'll be entered into a competition
where we're giving away three mcu box
sets on the 30th of january all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
interview we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one on screen right now so
if that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the perfect scene in
spider-man noway home in which we talk
about what it meant for andrew
garfield's peter parker to catch mj we
break down the entire thing and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
cried during that scene which i'd i
didn't i swear now without the way yeah
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you on the next
one yeah i'll go after gonna have to go
wipe my eyes you take care of yourself
peace